نمضي الان الى اعلى
الى المقر الرئيسي للبرج
هنا تدار كل العمليات الفنيه
والعمليات الاستراتيجيه لعمليه الملاحه
الجويه
هذه الاجهزه
التواصل والاتصال
يبدو انها مدمره بالكامل
واستقبال الطائرات
عبر اجهزه الرادر محمد بالنسبه
هنا هذه الصور لهذه الاجهزه اللاسلكيه
يبدو انها خارج الخدمه تماما الان كانت
نتيجه اشتباكات حصلت في هذه المواقع
تدمير للعناصر الدعم السريع ربما التي
كانت موجوده قبل انسحابها ماذا يقول
هو مؤكد خالد
المطروحه الان بان الاشتباكات كانت عنيفه
كل ما يحدث من ضرر هو نتيجه لهذا
الاشتباكات نتيجه للقصف العنيف الذي شهدته
هذه المنطقه
هذا ما يمكن ان نؤكد عليه بان الضرر وقع
نتيجه لعمل عسكري كانت هذه المنطقه من
المطار
مسرحا
وكانت ارضيه لكل العمليات العسكريه القصف
المدفعي القصف العنيف
حجم الضرر
هذا الدمار الذي لحق بالمطار لحق بالقاعده
لحق بهذا البرج لهذه القاعده وهذا المطار
الذي يمثل احد اهم المطارات في المنطقه
الاقليميه لانه يطل على الاتجاه الشمالي
للسودان على حدود السودان مع دوله مصر
منهم مباشره يمكن ان يتم التنسيق كما فعل
مسبقا الجيش السوداني مع عدد من جيوش
الدول في المنطقه الاقليميه
ايضا يعتبر هذا المطار بديلا لمطار
الخرطوم الدولي اذا ما حدثت اي متغيرات في
مطار الخرطوم يتم الاستعانه بهذا المطار
عليه فان برج المراقبه يمثل اولويه في ان
يستعد
عبر توفير كل ما من شانه ان يسمح لهذا
البرج ان يعاود عمله وان تستكمل الاجهزه
التي
دمرت خلال الاشتباكات الاخيره
يبدو خالد بان هذا هو ما سمح به الوقت
وعكس كل ما يدور الان في هذه القاعده التي
وصلنا الى قمه الهرم هرم المراقبه فيها
وتابعنا حجم الضرر الذي لحق به المستندات
ولحق بالادوات المكتبيه ولحق به
ديسك المعلومات الخاص بالعمليات الجويه
التي كانت تدور في هذه المنطقه
للعمل وللخدمه لن يكون في وقت
قصير ربما هل هناك اي ضرر وقع على مدرج
المطار الذي تهبطه تقلع منه الطائرات
مدرج المطار مدرج المطار الذي يمتد لي نحو
اربعه كيلومترات لم يتاثر بصوره مباشره
ولكن الضرر هو ضرر جزئي كما اكد مسؤولون
هنا بمطار مروي الدولي جل الضرر خالد هو
يتعلق ببرج المراقبه والاليات التي تعاون
هذا المطار على العمل والاجهزه الحساسه
اجهزه المراقبه الجويه هي من تاثر المرافق
الحيويه تاثرت تدرك تماما بان مثل هذه
المواقع الاستراتيجيه الاجهزه المتعلقه
بالاتصالات وبالمراقبه وبتبادل المعلومات
هي من الحساسيه ومن الاهميه بمكان اي ضرر
يقع على هذه الاجهزه وهذه المعدات وهذه
الاليات الفنيه سيعقد صعوبه ان يعود
المطار ليعمل بكفاءته لكن
مختصون ايضا واداره هذا المطار ذكرت لنا
يوم الامس بانهم يعملون الان على حجم او
على حصر الاضرار وعلى رفع تقييم اول يدفع
به مباشره الى الجهات المختصه في الخرطوم
لمعرفه المدى الزمني والامكانيات الماديه
المتطلب توفرها حتى يعود هذا المطار الى
عمله كما كان سابقا
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات